do you ever feel like Dark Souls doesn't
have enough unpronounceable bosses worry
no more because now we have the you Dex
crumb growing gum Grunk I'm Kate and
this is your gamespot news update bandai
namco has released a new series of
high-definition screen shots from its
upcoming action role-playing game dark
souls 3 the images showcase some new
characters armor sets and locations
players can expect to encounter in the
game in particular there's a new boss
named the you Dex gunder this enemy
wields a long spear like weapon and is
shown with a dark mass exploding from
its form in combat so as well encounter
this pass upon being revived in the
untended graves as a nun Kindle the
images also reveal the Firelink shrine
where a fire keeper resides and serves
players on their long and arduous
journey the location says the starting
area for new players in the game dark
souls is scheduled to launch on April
twelfth outside of Japan for the
playstation 4 xbox one and pc via steam
you can check out the system
requirements on gamespot com will you be
getting dark souls 3 on launch let me
know in the comments or come and find me
on Twitter I'm at how not to draw thanks
for watching and for all your gaming and
entertainment news keep it gamespot see
you at the bonfire friends